[Music]
hello and welcome to atp report
i'm barry nussbaum
let's start off with your homework
assignment atp people out there around
the world take out your cell phone if
you haven't done it yet take out a blank
text message on your phone and send the
message truth t-r-u-t-h in the message
box and address it to eight eight two
zero two push send you'll be signed up
in a heartbeat you'll be on our mailing
list and you'll get all of our content
absolutely free we have a very special
guest today robert spencer is with us
as you all know from many appearances on
atp report robert is the founder of
jihad watch um
the author of 23 best-selling books on
uh islamic jihad uh telling the story
all the way from the beginning to
current events you should check out his
website
welcome robert spencer good to talk to
you barry as always
thanks for coming on as usual let's
start off with your favorite topic
that's in quotes
uh the iranian mullahs are nothing if
not vindictive there's a report out now
that at least two iranians belonging to
the islamic revolutionary guard corps
the cuds force have been plotting to
assassinate former national security
adviser john bolton the justice
department knows about it has an
investigation but
as you point out on your website there
are no indictments it might be
because the biden administration will do
anything
to prevent the iran nuclear deal from
not happening is it really possible
robert that the united states will
prioritize a new nuclear deal
over everything or anything iran might
do including assassinating the national
security advisor
that does seem to be the case barry uh
they know who these men are who were
plotting they know what they were up to
they
were committing offenses that are indeed
indictable and yet no indictments are
forthcoming
and it seems clear that above all the
biden administration does not want to
offend the mullahs at a time when
they're about to conclude this new deal
which incidentally
the biden administration has outsourced
to a russian diplomat
mikhail uyanov
who has been in charge of the
negotiations for the united states with
iran and leonov has reported that the
iranians have gotten everything that
they wanted and more
he didn't say anything about the deal
being good for the united states
does that link up to what you know i
heard that a number of
top u.s negotiators walked out and quit
they were so disgusted that the united
states wasn't negotiating that we were
capitulating yes three negotiators in
the biden administration and so we have
to remember these are not like
maga hat wearing trump supporters these
guys were in the biden administration
they wanted a nuclear deal with iran
but they saw that the biden
administration was giving away the house
and they couldn't get behind that so
they quit
if your own people are bailing on you my
gosh how bad is this deal gonna be i
i'm scared to find out and supposedly
we're gonna know in a week or two yes
that's right um there's a there's a
group americans for peace now it's one
of those
peace groups
that basically hates the jewish state
and there was just a webinar where our
the united states ambassador to israel
tom knightis
made a speech about how there must be a
two-state solution and israel's in the
way and it's not good for the
palestinians and there's four or five
key issues that he brings up constantly
and his first key issue
this is so silly
the palestinians need 5g
and if they get 5g
that he's been pounding on the table
about there could be peace let me ask
you a question besides that completely
stupid comment how is it possible that
our ambassador would say you know
the palestinians aren't perfect either
because they pay
palestinians to murder jews
now that's not like a little minor
infraction you know like speeding
or uh forgetting to mow your lawn when
you're in a homeowner's association he
considers that a minor problem because
the palestinians pay uh palestinians to
kill jews i i don't get
how we have gone so insanely
into their camp
that we think that's hard to figure out
a solution to this ambassador says he's
working on a solution can't we just tell
them don't kill jews
well you know something interestingly
enough the trump administration told
them that and cut the palestinians off
and the taylor force act was passed that
forbade u.s taxpayer money being given
to any entity that funded terrorism
which should have cut the palestinians
off forever but the biden administration
turned the eighth faucet back on
and is giving millions and billions of
dollars to the palestinians
in defiance of the taylor force act and
an open defiance of it because they
actually say no no no see this is
humanitarian aid so that's okay but
there's no exception in the taylor force
act for humanitarian aid and so they're
just completely ignoring the law of the
united states in order to fund these
jihadis and then they turn around and
say gee this is a problem these guys are
paying terrorists well they knew that
already they knew that they knew that
there were provisions to protect the
american taxpayer from that from being
involved in that and they ignored it all
and so it's all on them
yeah very well said robert and we we
both remember the discussion in the
white house
where trump
told the palestinian authority stop
killing jews or i'm going to stop giving
you money
mahmoud abbas promised he would do it
went back to ramallah and reinstituted
the program literally instantly and as
you said
trump was a man of his word and cut off
the money and now we're paying them in
violation of federal law
to kill jews now speaking of where the
money's going i've got a great one for
you and this was off your website i mean
this is really good stuff you're
publishing
the u.s central command general mckenzie
has said that iran's missile force is
the greatest threat today to middle east
security they have an arsenal
of long-range ballistic missiles they've
been testing for years so for seven
years they've been pouring
enormous amounts of money into ballistic
missile delivery systems where'd they
get the money robert as you said from us
that's right we gave them billions from
the iran deal that was supposed to be
this was obama's speech remember
invested in humanitarian aid and blah
blah blah
we literally paid them billions to build
missiles to blow us and israel up
is this as insane to you as it is to me
oh yeah and it's worse because the obama
administration also knew
that they were going to use the money to
fund hamas and hezbollah not to feed
their own people and that's exactly what
they did the jihad terror groups that
are clients of the islamic republic of
iran got a huge boost in their funding
at the time of the iran nuclear deal and
now with this new nuclear deal it looks
as if they're going to get 150
billion dollars
and that is once again not going to go
to the iranian people it's going to go
to hamas to palestinian islamic jihad to
hezbollah and also very little known to
leftist groups communist groups around
the world because the islamic republic
has been discovered in spain for example
to be funding them
as well as jihad groups it seems that
what they want to do of course above all
is destabilize and ultimately destroy
the west and so marxist parties will do
just as well for that
well there's a
revolutionary group with a formerly
great name and
reputation called amnesty international
the the usa director came out with one
of the stupidest comments i have ever
heard
uh this guy was speaking his name is
paul o'brien uh in washington and he was
commenting robert on a 2020 national
poll that found 80 percent of american
jews consider themselves supporters of
israel 80
and this nut says i don't believe that
poll my gut tells me that jewish people
in the united states just want to know
there's a sustainable place there but it
shouldn't be a jewish state and this guy
actually said
he actually
said israel shouldn't exist as a jewish
state i wonder has amnesty international
ever come out and called for the
destruction of a state
anywhere in the world i think the answer
is obviously no and why is it okay for
this peace group
to advocate for the elimination of a
sovereign nation that's our ally
it's interesting to note that the whole
idea of the palestinians as a people was
never known before the 1960s it was
invented by the kgb in collaboration
with yasser arafat as a rhetorical stick
to beat israel with and of course it's
been incredibly effective because before
that israel was facing 22 hostile arab
states and it was the tiny david versus
this massive goliath so they created an
even smaller people
and then claimed that the rapacious
israeli war machine was oppressing them
now that was an idea born
in the center of leftism the soviet
union
and it is still an idea that is current
on the left that it would be just a
matter of social justice to destroy
israel essentially and to
let the local arabs overwhelm it
demographically if no if if not
militarily and so
this guy's
leftism is showing in saying this that
this is something that the israelis
ought to do actually if the israelis
ceased to exist as a jewish state there
would be a genocide of the jews because
the palestinian arabs would pursue the
jihad imperative and this is something
that the palestinian leaders have made
clear
many many times that not a single jew
would exist in a palestinian state
and any kind of hybrid state they would
ultimately work to take over
consequently this guy is essentially
calling for a new genocide of the jews
and that is
of a peace with the whole birth of the
palestinian idea
in the annals of the far left in the in
the in the think tanks of the far left
let me pile on if i might you point out
on your site
that
amnesty international tweets have been
analyzed over the preceding number of
months
they published
132 tweets
condemning israel
and for the entire rest of the world
everywhere there's absolute genocide
slaughter
of magnitudes in the millions
just 13 tweets about the rest of the
world combined
and 10 times that number
just about how horrible
israel is
is their agenda as obvious to you as it
seems to be to me like
let's just get rid of the jews oh
absolutely and you know it's the same
thing at the u.n
where they have a standing article on
their agenda item seven that is about
palestinian oppression by israel there
is no other country that comes in for
the routine condemnation that israel
does at the u.n and it's very clear why
because the un's largest voting bloc is
the organization of islamic cooperation
56 muslim countries plus the
palestinians and they essentially
control what the u.n says so israel
instead of genuine massive human rights
offenders like north korea israel gets
the brunt of its criticism they and they
ignore the real human rights offenders
sure makes you miss nikki haley doesn't
it at the u.n standing up for what's
right
wow
yeah
robert tell people where they can find
out about you and follow your brilliant
work would you please ghodwatch.org is
the only site in the world that tracks
jihad activity every day and then
there's jihad watch rs on twitter
there's jihad watch facebook group my
books are at
amazon.com barnes and noble and wherever
self-respecting books are sold
by his books
read his writings you'll learn a lot
thanks robert for coming on and all of
you out there in atp lang we sure
appreciate you joining us today remember
if you didn't do it earlier take out
your cell phone and text the word truth
in your message box and address it to
88202 push send we'll sign you up for
free and you'll never pay for our
content
for atp report
i'm berry nussbaum